ça sent encore les vacances sur l'île d'
léron alors que le ciel se voile peu à
peu sur une saison plutôt réussie 8000
campeurs propriétaires de leur terrain
doivent tout simplement décamper avant
le 30 septembre quand on a eu nos actes
notariés d'accord c'était bien indiqué
que c'était non constructible mais
absolument pas indiqué qu'on avait pas
le droit de disons de mettre une
caravane ou alors mob moi sur le mien
c'est pas notifié c'est pas normal c'est
pas une chose normale on est
propriétaire not terrain pas nous
laisser nous installer à ce momentlà il
y a 17 ans la préfecture de Charente
Maritime relayée par les h maires de la
communauté de commune de l'île d'Oléron
veut tout simplement faire appliquer la
loi littorale et préserver
l'environnement en mettant fin à
certains abus installé depuis plus de 20
ans certains campeurs bénéficiaient de
tolérance mais pas d'autorisation
officielle il faut que ces espaces qui
sont malgré tout occupés par des
campeurs isolés retrouvent leur vocation
d'origine il me semble que que cette
légitime de la part des élus et non
seulement au léronis d'ailleurs parce
que à ma connaissance surt le littoral
atlantique se pose ce problème là
actuellement à la pointe du combat
Maurice grriison ce retraité ancien
agent d'assurance propriétaire d'un
terrain et d'un mobilehome veut négocier
avec les maire au cas par cas
juridiquement parlant nous ne sommes pas
défendables puisque nous sommes derhors
la loi il faut donc essayer de passer
autre trouver une solution à mer avec
Monsieur les ma et le président de la
Communauté des Communes et si le
dialogue s'avère impossible les campeurs
envisage d'organiser une grande
manifestation sur l'île d'
léron